Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In 1991, the old London Quefure was well known to the people of Portland, a small harborside city 350 kilometres southwest of Melbourne. Located on the corners of Julia Street and Bentink Street, two of the main shopping strips in town,
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。1991年，老伦敦美发沙龙（Old London Coiffure）在波特兰（Portland）的居民中广为人知，这是一个位于墨尔本西南350公里处的小型海滨城市。它坐落在朱莉娅街（Julia Street）和本廷克街（Bentink Street）的拐角处，这是镇上两条主要的购物街之一。
the hair salon had been servicing residents of the community for 20 years. But it hadn't always been that way. Just a stone's throw from Portland Bay, the two-story bluestone building was built in 1844. It had once served as a hotel called the Olde, Old London Inn, offering residential accommodation, meeting rooms and a boarding stable. The ground floor had since been converted to the hair salon and various office spaces, while the upper level housed a dental surgery.
这家美发沙龙已经为社区居民服务了20年。但情况并非一直如此。这座两层楼的蓝石建筑距离波特兰湾仅一箭之遥，建于1844年。它曾经是一家名为“老伦敦旅馆”（Olde, Old London Inn）的酒店，提供住宿、会议室和寄宿马厩。此后，底层被改建为美发沙龙和各种办公空间，而上层则设有一间牙科诊所。
Despite the many changes the Old London building had gone through over the years, it retained its original Georgian-era charm and was still considered one of the most distinguished buildings in Portland. 49-year-old Claire Aycock could be found working two days a week at the old London coiffure. She was incredibly well-liked around town, with her warm and generous nature affording her loyal client base. Her work days were relatively uneventful, save for the odd piece of town gossip, and more recently, petty theft. Around April 1991, the owner of the salon had arrived at work to discover that a chair behind the reception desk had been overturned and approximately $30 in
尽管多年来老伦敦大楼经历了许多变化，但它保留了最初的乔治亚时代魅力，仍被认为是波特兰最杰出的建筑之一。49岁的克莱尔·艾科克（Claire Aycock）每周在老伦敦美发沙龙工作两天。她在镇上非常受欢迎，她热情慷慨的性格为她赢得了忠实的客户群。她的工作日相对平静，除了偶尔听到镇上的闲言碎语，以及最近发生的轻微盗窃案。1991年4月左右，沙龙老板上班时发现接待台后面的一把椅子被推翻了，大约30美元的硬币从收银机里被偷走了。
coins had been stolen from the register. The salon doors were all locked and there were no signs of a break-in. Police were notified, but there was little they could do and it was brushed off as a minor incident. A few weeks later, on the afternoon of Wednesday, April 17, 1991, Claire was working alone when she turned around to find an unfamiliar long-haired man standing behind her. His presence in the salon hadn't triggered the bell which was attached to the front door handle, giving Claire a significant fright. The man didn't have an appointment, but he requested that Claire give him a trim. Something about his eyes and the way he carried himself completely unnerved Claire.
沙龙的门都锁着，没有闯入的迹象。警方接到通知，但他们能做的很少，这件事被当作小事处理了。几周后，1991年4月17日星期三下午，克莱尔独自工作时，转身发现一个陌生的长发男子站在她身后。他在沙龙里的出现并没有触发前门把手上的铃铛，这让克莱尔大吃一惊。那个男人没有预约，但他要求克莱尔给他修剪一下头发。他眼神里的某种东西以及他的举止让克莱尔感到非常不安。
As they spoke, the man made several derogatory and abusive claims. comments, telling Claire that he didn't like hairdressers. He eventually left without getting a haircut. As soon as he was out of sight, Claire locked the salon and closed up shop for the day. The interaction completely rattled her. Claire was typically a calm and confident person, but when she told friends about the incident, her demeanour changed completely. She described the would-be customer as a horrible man with creepy eyes and said she'd never been so frightened in her life. Out of sight didn't necessarily mean out of mind. Just before the man left, he had warned of his intentions to return.
在他们交谈时，那个男人发表了几句贬损和辱骂性的言论，告诉克莱尔他不喜欢理发师。他最终没有理发就离开了。他一消失在视线中，克莱尔就锁上了沙龙，关门歇业了。这次互动让她彻底心慌意乱。克莱尔通常是一个冷静自信的人，但当她向朋友讲述这件事时，她的神态完全变了。她形容那个潜在的顾客是一个可怕的男人，有着令人毛骨悚然的眼睛，并说她这辈子从来没有这么害怕过。看不见并不一定意味着不想。就在那个男人离开之前，他曾警告说他打算回来。
Roughly two weeks after the encounter with the horrible man, May 3, 1991 started out like any other Friday for Claire. After a typical morning at home, she made lunch for her husband Peter and one of his friends before leaving for her shift at the salon. She brought with her a jumper she was in the process of knitting for her soon-to-be-born grandson. Claire's daughter lived in Melbourne and was about to give birth to her first baby. Claire had been diligently saving to visit her new grandson and shower him with gifts. She'd managed to save $500, which she carried around in an old wallet, and she worked on her knitting project whenever she got a spare moment between clients.
在与那个可怕的男人相遇大约两周后，1991年5月3日，对克莱尔来说，这一天像往常的星期五一样开始了。在家里度过了一个典型的早晨后，她为丈夫彼得（Peter）和他的一个朋友做了午餐，然后去沙龙上班。她随身带着一件她正在为即将出生的孙子编织的毛衣。克莱尔的女儿住在墨尔本，即将生下她的第一个孩子。克莱尔一直在努力存钱去探望她的新孙子，并送给他礼物。她设法存了500美元，装在一个旧钱包里，只要在客户之间的空闲时间，她就会做她的编织项目。
Claire Aycock's had lived in Portland for 15 years. With the population of roughly 9,000 residents, it was not only considered a safe place to live. The laid-back lifestyle was also a perfect fit for Claire's personality. She was passionate about three things above all else, her family, animals and gardening. The Acox's three children had since flown the nest, giving Claire more time to focus on her hobbies and work. Claire had three appointments scheduled for Friday afternoon, one of which was with her regular client, 58-year-old Margaret Penny. Margaret and her husband of 36 years had relocated to Portland only seven months prior, having lived in town previously before moving elsewhere to raise their two children. Margaret was a house-proud woman who prided herself on her appearance. As such, she had a recurring
克莱尔·艾科克在波特兰住了15年。这里人口约9000人，不仅被认为是一个安全的居住地，悠闲的生活方式也非常适合克莱尔的性格。她最热衷于三件事：家庭、动物和园艺。艾科克家的三个孩子都已经离家独立，这让克莱尔有更多时间专注于她的爱好和工作。克莱尔周五下午安排了三个预约，其中一个是她的老客户，58岁的玛格丽特·彭尼（Margaret Penny）。玛格丽特和她结婚36年的丈夫七个月前才搬回波特兰，他们之前曾住在这里，后来搬到别处抚养他们的两个孩子。玛格丽特是一位以家为荣的女性，她对自己的外表感到自豪。因此，她有一个固定的
appointment with Claire Aycock's every Friday afternoon to have her hair set and styled. On this particular day, Margaret was also scheduled to have her hair coloured in preparation for a week-long trip visiting her daughter Jacqueline in Melbourne the following morning. For several weeks, Margaret and her husband Robert had been looking after Jacqueline's five-year-old daughter, Alice, not her real name. Margaret was a doting grandmother and she spent the morning entertaining Alice at home while Robert did some yard work and ran errands around town. Margaret usually took Alice with her to the salon to have her hair braided, but on this particular day, Alice was going to stay home to help Robert build a swing in the backyard. As Margaret's 2pm appointment approached, she was running
每周五下午与克莱尔·艾科克的预约，去整理和做发型。在这一天，玛格丽特还计划染发，为第二天去墨尔本探望女儿杰奎琳（Jacqueline）的为期一周的旅行做准备。几周来，玛格丽特和她的丈夫罗伯特（Robert）一直在照顾杰奎琳五岁的女儿爱丽丝（Alice，化名）。玛格丽特是一位溺爱孙女的祖母，她花了一个上午在家里招待爱丽丝，而罗伯特则在做庭院工作和在镇上跑腿。玛格丽特通常会带爱丽丝去沙龙编辫子，但这一天，爱丽丝要留在家里帮罗伯特在后院建一个秋千。随着玛格丽特下午2点的预约临近，她
behind schedule. This stressed her out as she prided herself on being punctual and organised. By the time Robert moved the car onto the street for her, Margaret was in a hurry. She rushed off, making a quick stop at the Ocean Pier tea rooms. The cafe was just a few buildings down from the old London coiffure. Margaret had made plans to meet her friend Shirley Endersby for afternoon tea there after her hair appointment at 315. Worried that the staff would stop preparing food by that time, Margaret ducked in to pre-order some sandwiches before hurrying down the street to the salon. The old London building backed onto a communal courtyard shared by multiple businesses.
进度落后了。这让她感到压力很大，因为她以准时和有条理而自豪。当罗伯特把车开到街上等她时，玛格丽特很匆忙。她匆匆赶去，在海洋码头茶室（Ocean Pier tea rooms）短暂停留。这家咖啡馆距离老伦敦美发沙龙只有几栋楼远。玛格丽特计划在下午3点15分做完头发后，去那里和她的朋友雪莉·恩德斯比（Shirley Endersby）喝下午茶。担心工作人员到那时会停止准备食物，玛格丽特冲进去预订了一些三明治，然后匆匆赶往沙龙。老伦敦大楼的后面是一个由多家企业共用的公共庭院。
This space could be accessed via large iron gates which were kept open during office hours. At around 3.30, two men who worked in the office across the courtyard heard high-pitched screams coming from outside. They peered out the window. One of them saw the rear screen door to the salon fling open as the wooden door behind it slammed close. The screams then stopped as quickly as they'd started. Assuming it was just kids running around, the office workers didn't give it any more thought.
这个空间可以通过办公时间保持开启的大型铁门进入。下午3点30分左右，两名在庭院对面办公室工作的男子听到外面传来尖锐的尖叫声。他们向窗外望去。其中一人看到沙龙的后纱门猛地打开，后面的木门随之砰地关上。尖叫声随即戛然而止。以为只是孩子们在跑来跑去，办公室职员们没再多想。
At 3.40pm, Shirley Endersby sat watching the clock at the Ocean Pier tea rooms. Margaret Penny was 25 minutes late. This was incredibly unlike her. Shirley decided to duck to the old London coiffure to see what the hold-up was. When she arrived at the salon and pushed on the front door, she was surprised to find her was locked. This was strange given that the salon wasn't scheduled to close until later in the evening. Shirley knocked aloudly.
下午3点40分，雪莉·恩德斯比坐在海洋码头茶室看着时钟。玛格丽特·彭尼迟到了25分钟。这太不像她了。雪莉决定去老伦敦美发沙龙看看出了什么事。当她到达沙龙并推开前门时，惊讶地发现门锁着。这很奇怪，因为沙龙计划在晚上晚些时候才关门。雪莉大声敲门。
There was no answer. She knew Margaret couldn't be too far away. She could see her car parked on Benton Street nearby. Shirley walked to the courtyard at the rear of the salon, but the back door was locked too. Shirley banged on the door. There was no response. Shirley returned to the tea rooms,
没有人回答。她知道玛格丽特不可能走得太远。她可以看到她的车停在附近的本廷克街上。雪莉走到沙龙后面的庭院，但后门也锁着。雪莉敲打着门。没有回应。雪莉回到茶室，
keeping an eye out for Margaret on the streets. By this point, it was nearing 4pm. It was completely out of character for Margaret Penny to be 45 minutes late, and Shirley was unsure what to do next. She got in her car. As she drove past the old London Quifure, she saw that the lights were on inside. Shirley wondered whether she had gotten the times mixed up. Perhaps Margaret had said 4.15, and was still mid-appointment.
留意着街上的玛格丽特。此时，时间已接近下午4点。玛格丽特·彭尼迟到45分钟完全不符合她的性格，雪莉不知道接下来该怎么办。她上了车。当她开车经过老伦敦美发沙龙时，看到里面的灯亮着。雪莉怀疑自己是否记错了时间。也许玛格丽特说的是4点15分，还在做头发。
Maybe she'd brought her granddaughter Alice with her and the young girl had to be locked the door while playing around. Shirley drove the short distance to her house and called Margaret's husband, Robert Penny. Robert was home with Alice. He recalled that Margaret had rushed off to her hair appointment in a hurry, but he hadn't heard from her since. Shirley drove back into town, keeping an eye out for her friend. She checked in a couple of shops before walking back to the salon. By this point, it was 4.15pm. Both the front and back doors were still locked, and again, Shirley's knocks went unanswered. As she passed the window to the shampoo room at the rear of the building, she noticed that the lights were off. Assuming this meant the salon was closed for the day, she drove home once more and called the salon owner, Kay Edwards, to see what was going on. When Kay heard that the salon was locked, she was puzzled.
也许她带了孙女爱丽丝一起来，小女孩在玩耍时把门锁上了。雪莉开车回到家，给玛格丽特的丈夫罗伯特·彭尼打了电话。罗伯特和爱丽丝在家。他回忆说玛格丽特匆匆忙忙去理发了，但从那以后就没再收到她的消息。雪莉开车回到镇上，留意着她的朋友。她在几家商店里找了找，然后走回沙龙。此时，已经是下午4点15分了。前门和后门仍然锁着，雪莉的敲门声再次无人应答。当她经过大楼后面洗发室的窗户时，注意到灯关着。以为这意味着沙龙今天已经关门了，她又开车回家，给沙龙老板凯·爱德华兹（Kay Edwards）打电话，看看发生了什么事。当凯听说沙龙锁着时，她感到很困惑。
She worked at the salon most days, except Wednesday morning and Friday afternoon, when Claire was rostered on. Kay knew that Claire had several appointments scheduled for that afternoon, including one for 4.30pm. It made no sense that the salon doors would be locked or the lights to the shampoo room would be off. Both the front and back doors were always left open during business hours as clients used both entrances, and the lights to the shampoo room were always kept on. Kay hung up her call with Shirley and dialed the salon twice. The phone rang out both times.
她大部分时间都在沙龙工作，除了周三上午和周五下午，那是克莱尔排班的时间。凯知道克莱尔那天下午安排了几个预约，包括一个下午4点30分的。沙龙门锁着或者洗发室灯关着根本说不通。在营业时间内，前门和后门总是开着的，因为客户会使用两个入口，而且洗发室的灯总是开着的。凯挂断了与雪莉的电话，拨打了两次沙龙的电话。两次电话都响了很久没人接。
She made the two-minute drive to see for herself what was going on. As soon as Kay arrived via the rear courtyard, she knew something wasn't quite right. The screen door, which was always kept closed, was wide open, while the solid wooden door was locked. Kay walked around to the front entrance and unlocked the main door. The salon had three rooms, a reception area, the main hairdressing space, and a small shampoo room.
她开了两分钟的车去看看发生了什么事。凯一从后院到达，就知道有些不对劲。平时总是关着的纱门大开着，而坚固的木门却锁着。凯走到前门，打开了主门。沙龙有三个房间：接待区、主美发区和一个小洗发室。
When Kay entered the reception area, she noticed several items were out of place. A stool behind the front desk had been turned on its side. The cash register was closed, but a 20-cent transaction had been rung up on the till. This alone was odd. Nothing in the salon cost 20 cents. Kaye peered into the main salon, which was separated down the middle by a mirrored partition with three chairs on either side. One chair had been moved from its usual spot and three magazines sat in its place. A trolley that usually sat against the back wall had been moved to the archway leading to the shampoo room.
当凯进入接待区时，她注意到几件东西放错了位置。前台后面的一张凳子侧翻在地。收银机关着，但上面显示了一笔20美分的交易。单这一点就很奇怪。沙龙里没有任何东西值20美分。凯向主沙龙望去，中间被一个镜面隔断隔开，两边各有三把椅子。一把椅子从原来的位置移开了，上面放着三本杂志。一个平时靠在后墙上的推车被移到了通往洗发室的拱门处。
Kay was too afraid to venture any further. She ran upstairs to the dental surgery and told the receptionist, There's something strange downstairs. The receptionist agreed to accompany Kay to check it out. As the two women entered the main salon, Kay noticed a black handbag lying on the floor with its content strewn about. Her anxiety peeped. The two women apprehensively made their way towards the entrance of the shampoo room. It was a small dark space positioned towards the rear of
凯太害怕了，不敢再往前走。她跑到楼上的牙科诊所，告诉接待员：“楼下有些奇怪的事情。”接待员同意陪凯去查看一下。当两名女子进入主沙龙时，凯注意到地板上躺着一个黑色手提包，里面的东西散落一地。她的焦虑达到了顶点。两名女子忐忑不安地走向洗发室的入口。那是一个位于大楼后部的小而黑暗的空间，
the building containing three black chairs and a hair-washing basin. That's when Kay saw it. Two pairs of legs sprawled out on the ground. Junior constable Tim Aycock had just arrived arrived at work and was manning the desk at the Portland Police Station when a colleague told him that something major was unfolding down the street. Two women had been found dead in the old London coiffure. Constable Acox froze. While Portland had its fair share of smaller, mostly drug-related crimes, murders were unheard of. Worse still, Claire Acox was his mother and he knew that she worked at the old London coiffure on Friday afternoons. As Constable Acox continued to field calls in a state of shock,
里面有三把黑色的椅子和一个洗头盆。就在那时，凯看到了。两双腿在地板上伸展开来。初级警员蒂姆·艾科克（Tim Aycock）刚到岗，正在波特兰警察局值班，这时一位同事告诉他，街上正在发生一件大事。在老伦敦美发沙龙发现了两名死者。艾科克警员僵住了。虽然波特兰有相当多的小型、主要是与毒品有关的犯罪，但谋杀案闻所未闻。更糟糕的是，克莱尔·艾科克是他的母亲，他知道她周五下午在老伦敦美发沙龙工作。当艾科克警员在震惊中继续接听电话时，
investigators examined the scene. Just inside the doorway to the shampoo room, the bodies of Margaret Penny and Claire Acox lay head to toe, covered with black hairdressing capes. Blood pulled on the floor around them. Margaret lay on her stomach with her throat slit. There were numerous stab wounds and abrasions to her back and abdomen, and five of her ribs were fractured. Her hands rested at her chest, bound together with a black towel.
调查人员检查了现场。在洗发室门口内侧，玛格丽特·彭尼和克莱尔·艾科克的尸体头脚相对地躺着，盖着黑色的理发斗篷。地板上积聚着血迹。玛格丽特俯卧着，喉咙被割开。她的背部和腹部有许多刺伤和擦伤，五根肋骨骨折。她的双手放在胸前，用一条黑色的毛巾绑在一起。
A grey electrical cord had been used to bind her ankles together, and the cord was also looped around her neck and tied to a nearby chair. Claire Aycock's lay alongside her. Like Margaret, Claire's throat had been slit and her torso. also was peppered with stub wounds and abrasions. Although Claire had fewer wounds than Margaret, hers were significantly deeper. A clear wrap had been tied around her neck and the electrical cord of a curling wand had been loosely tied to a nearby chair. The contents of Claire's handbag had been dumped in the nearby basin, while the contents of Margaret's bag were scattered near the shampoo room door. Both women were fully dressed, except for Margaret's eyeglasses and one of Claire's shoes, which were lying nearby.
一条灰色的电线被用来将她的脚踝绑在一起，电线还绕在她的脖子上，并系在附近的一把椅子上。克莱尔·艾科克躺在她旁边。和玛格丽特一样，克莱尔的喉咙也被割开了，她的躯干上也布满了刺伤和擦伤。虽然克莱尔的伤口比玛格丽特少，但她的伤口明显更深。一条透明的保鲜膜缠在她的脖子上，卷发棒的电线被松散地系在附近的一把椅子上。克莱尔手提包里的东西被倒在附近的洗头盆里，而玛格丽特包里的东西散落在洗发室门口附近。两名女子都穿着整齐，除了玛格丽特的眼镜和克莱尔的一只鞋子，它们掉在附近。
While there were no signs of sexual assault, it was clear that a struggle had taken place. Both women were covered in defensive wounds, and blood spatter covered the walls. The forensic evidence indicated that the women had been attacked while forced to sit in the shampooing chairs. They eventually dropped forward and bled out on the floor where the killer covered their bodies. A majority of the injuries had been inflicted using a sharp-edged knife, which was nowhere to be seen. But on Margaret's back and chest were also a series of narrow round puncture wounds. The weapon that caused these injuries wasn't immediately clear. What was obvious was that this had been a cold-blooded and disres.
虽然没有性侵犯的迹象，但很明显发生过挣扎。两名女子身上都布满了防御性伤口，墙上溅满了血迹。法医证据表明，这两名女子是在被迫坐在洗发椅上时遭到袭击的。她们最终向前倒下，在地板上流血而死，凶手随后盖住了她们的尸体。大部分伤口是用锋利的刀造成的，但刀不见了。但在玛格丽特的背部和胸部，还有一系列狭窄的圆形穿刺伤。造成这些伤害的武器尚不清楚。显而易见的是，这是一场冷血且极其
vicious attack, unlike anything many of the officers had ever seen before. All up, the perpetrator had taken off with almost $900 in cash. This included the $500 that Claire had been saving for her grandson and approximately $180 that Margaret had been carrying. Money had also been taken from the salon till, along with a check and a few miscellaneous items. But this didn't necessarily mean that the attack had been motivated by robbery. If the perpetrator had simply wanted money, it seemed odd that they'd gone to such extreme lengths. Both Claire and Margaret were also wearing several items of valuable jewelry. Margaret alone wore four gold rings, one of which contained a diamond, but the killer had made no attempt to remove them.
残忍的袭击，是许多警官以前从未见过的。总共，肇事者带走了近900美元现金。这包括克莱尔为孙子存的500美元和玛格丽特随身携带的大约180美元。沙龙收银机里的钱也被拿走了，还有一张支票和一些杂物。但这并不一定意味着袭击的动机是抢劫。如果肇事者只是想要钱，他们采取如此极端的手段似乎很奇怪。克莱尔和玛格丽特也都戴着几件贵重的珠宝。仅玛格丽特就戴着四枚金戒指，其中一枚镶有钻石，但凶手并没有试图取下它们。
inquiries quickly revealed that both Claire and Margaret were well-liked upstanding citizens with no known enemies. Both were happily married and each of their husbands had alibis that checked out. Peter Aycock's was playing golf with friends at the time of the crime, while Robert Penny was home with his granddaughter. Who would want to kill these two harmless, innocent women, and why? As Robert Penny expressed, when the delivered the news. How can you go to the hairdresser and not come back? The police soon learned about Claire Aycock's recent encounter with the so-called horrible man. There was no mention of him in the salon's appointment book.
调查很快显示，克莱尔和玛格丽特都是受人尊敬的正直公民，没有已知的敌人。两人婚姻幸福，她们各自的丈夫都有经得起推敲的不在场证明。彼得·艾科克在案发时正和朋友打高尔夫球，而罗伯特·彭尼则和孙女在家。谁会想杀害这两个无害、无辜的女性，为什么？正如罗伯特·彭尼在传达消息时所说：“你怎么能去理发店却回不来了呢？”警方很快得知了克莱尔·艾科克最近与那个所谓的“可怕男人”的相遇。沙龙的预约簿上没有提到他。
Although the old London coiffure did take the occasional male customer, their clientele were predominantly women. Other than the man's horrible eyes, the only thing Claire had mentioned about his appearance was that he had a long hair. Identifying him would be no easy task, but for investigators, finding the horrible man was a priority. They considered the possibility that he could have visited Claire Aycox at the salon to assess the location and to scope out the building layout. His comment about disliking hairdressers could be significant. Was this just an off-color remark, or did he have a genuine hate? of this profession and deliver on his threat to return. The only discernible clue that the
虽然老伦敦美发沙龙确实偶尔会有男性顾客，但她们的客户主要是女性。除了那个男人可怕的眼睛外，克莱尔提到的关于他外表的唯一一点就是他留着长发。识别他并非易事，但对调查人员来说，找到这个“可怕的男人”是当务之急。他们考虑了他可能去沙龙找克莱尔以评估地点并查看建筑布局的可能性。他关于不喜欢理发师的评论可能很重要。这只是一个不得体的言论，还是他真的对这个职业有真正的仇恨，并兑现了他回来的威胁？唯一的线索是
offender had left behind was a partial bloody shoe print found near the entrance of the shampoo room. The defensive wounds on Claire and Margaret's hands suggested the killer might have been injured during the attack, but it was difficult to distinguish between the large quantities of blood found at the crime scene. Inquiries were made with hospitals and healthcare facilities, but no one had presented seeking treatment for cuts. Given that the murders had occurred within a salon, hair samples were everywhere. The salon was painstakingly vacuumed and the contents held in evidence, but identifying whether any of the hair belonged to the killer was near impossible. Hundreds of customers who had recently visited the salon were asked to volunteer their fingerprints
罪犯留下的唯一线索是在洗发室入口附近发现的一个部分血迹斑斑的鞋印。克莱尔和玛格丽特手上的防御性伤口表明凶手在袭击过程中可能受了伤，但很难区分犯罪现场发现的大量血迹。警方对医院和医疗机构进行了调查，但没有人因割伤寻求治疗。鉴于谋杀案发生在沙龙内，头发样本随处可见。沙龙经过了仔细的吸尘，内容物被作为证据保存，但要确定是否有任何头发属于凶手几乎是不可能的。数百名最近访问过沙龙的顾客被要求自愿提供指纹，
to be eliminated from the investigation. When each print was accounted for, only one remained, a partial print near the front door. While this was a promising lead, it didn't contain any blood, and investigators couldn't say for sure whether the print belonged to the killer. Claire Aycock's had tended to two clients earlier in the afternoon. Neither of them had noticed anything unusual about her demeanor, nor had they seen any suspicious activity at the salon. One recalled that a man had arrived via the rear door and asked Claire something, but the client had only heard the man's voice and didn't hear what he asked or get a look at him. A friend of Clare's had driven past the old London coiffure at around 305.
以便从调查中排除。当每个指纹都被核对后，只剩下一个，即前门附近的一个部分指纹。虽然这是一个有希望的线索，但它不含任何血迹，调查人员无法确定该指纹是否属于凶手。克莱尔·艾科克当天下午早些时候接待了两名客户。他们都没有注意到她有什么异常，也没有看到沙龙有什么可疑活动。其中一人回忆说，一名男子通过后门到达并问了克莱尔一些事情，但客户只听到了男子的声音，没有听到他问什么，也没有看清他。克莱尔的一位朋友在下午3点05分左右开车经过老伦敦美发沙龙。
Claire was standing on the opposite side of the street, holding her bag of knitting. The two acknowledged one another with a quick wave. This was the last time she was. seen alive. Investigators deduced that while Margaret's hair was setting, Claire had likely run across the street to retrieve the knitting from her car. This would have only taken her a couple of minutes. Based on the time that the bodies were discovered, this meant the crime occurred sometime between 305 and 4.30 p.m. Two other people had gone past the salon during that crucial 90-minute period. Margaret's friend Shirley Endersby at both 345 and 415 and another of Claire's clients at
克莱尔正站在街对面，手里拿着她的编织袋。两人挥手致意。这是她最后一次被活着看到。调查人员推断，当玛格丽特做头发时，克莱尔很可能跑过马路去车里取编织物。这只需要她几分钟时间。根据发现尸体的时间，这意味着犯罪发生在下午3点05分到4点30分之间的某个时间。在那关键的90分钟内，还有另外两个人经过沙龙。玛格丽特的朋友雪莉·恩德斯比在3点45分和4点15分，以及克莱尔的另一位客户在
4.30. Neither had seen or heard anything suspicious. Two office workers had heard high-pitched screams at 3.30pm, but they hadn't seen anything out of the ordinary. A dentist who worked upstairs also recalled hearing the sound of a woman crying out in disgust, but he couldn't be sure exactly what time. Investigators could only speculate over what occurred inside the old London coiffure. They believed the killer had acted alone. He likely entered the salon via the front door, possibly while Claire was retrieving the knitting from her car. Perhaps he intended to rob the place and was caught off guard upon finding Margaret inside. He could have ordered Margaret to the shampoo room, bound her to the chair, and then overpowered Claire upon her return.
4点30分。两人都没有看到或听到任何可疑的事情。两名办公室职员在下午3点30分听到了尖锐的尖叫声，但他们没有看到任何异常。一位在楼上工作的牙医也回忆说听到了一个女人厌恶地尖叫的声音，但他不能确定具体时间。调查人员只能推测老伦敦美发沙龙内发生了什么。他们认为凶手是单独行动的。他很可能从前门进入沙龙，可能是在克莱尔从车里取编织物时。也许他打算抢劫，但在发现玛格丽特在里面时措手不及。他可能命令玛格丽特去洗发室，把她绑在椅子上，然后在克莱尔回来时制服了她。
Or maybe the killer had burst in unexpectedly, ordering both women to the shampoo room where he launched his attack. While it couldn't be determined how long the women were held for, it was possible that the killer had spent up to 90 minutes on the scene. Claire's 430 appointment had arrived via the front door and seen nothing, making it likely the killer fled by the salon's rear door. There were only two possible escape routes. Either the killer had run through a dozen backyards to make a stealth getaway via a back lane, or he'd had to cross at least two main streets during peak hour. The savage attack had happened in broad daylight
或者凶手可能突然闯入，命令两名女子去洗发室，在那里发动了袭击。虽然无法确定两名女子被扣留了多久，但凶手可能在现场停留了长达90分钟。克莱尔4点30分的预约从前门到达，什么也没看到，这使得凶手很可能是从沙龙的后门逃走的。只有两条可能的逃跑路线。要么凶手穿过十几个后院，通过后巷悄悄逃走，要么他必须在高峰时段穿过至少两条主要街道。这场野蛮的袭击发生在光天化日之下，
at one of the busiest times of the day. A school was located just a few hundred meters down the road, and the crucial time period had occurred when students were knocking off for the weekend. Dozens of parents and children passed right by the old London Quafua around the time the attack was thought to have taken place. Given the amount of blood at the crime scene, it was indisputable that whoever had killed Claire and Margaret would have been covered in blood. Yet no one had witnessed anything suspicious. With no concrete sightings of the perpetrator, investigators queried who could be motivated to pull off such a violent and brazen crime. Was this a random opportunistic attack, or had someone deliberately targeted the two women?
在一天中最繁忙的时间之一。一条学校距离路边只有几百米，而关键时期发生在学生们周末放学的时候。在袭击被认为发生的时间前后，几十名家长和孩子从老伦敦美发沙龙旁边经过。鉴于犯罪现场的血迹，毫无疑问，杀死克莱尔和玛格丽特的人身上会沾满鲜血。然而没有人目击到任何可疑的事情。由于没有肇事者的确切目击记录，调查人员询问谁有动机实施如此暴力和厚颜无耻的犯罪。这是一次随机的机会性袭击，还是有人蓄意针对这两名女性？
Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Investigators on the Acox penny case had to consider all angles. Given that Margaret had a recurring appointment with Claire every Friday afternoon, it was possible that the killer could have known this and visited the salon with the intention of carrying out the attack. Alternatively, investigators also considered the possibility that the salon owner, Kay Edwards,
《案件档案》（Case File）稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持《案件档案》继续提供高质量的内容。艾科克-彭尼案的调查人员必须考虑所有角度。鉴于玛格丽特每周五下午都有与克莱尔的固定预约，凶手可能知道这一点，并带着实施袭击的意图访问了沙龙。或者，调查人员也考虑了沙龙老板凯·爱德华兹（Kay Edwards）
could have been the intended target, and Margaret and Claire were simply in the wrong place at the wrong time. But K2 was a well-liked law-abiding local with no enemies or nefarious connections. The possibility that any of the three women could have been specifically targeted just didn't make sense. In the days before computers, each piece of information had to be recorded by hand and then prioritized accordingly. The police quickly became overwhelmed. Pressure was on to solve the case quickly, but with the case, but with the police quickly, but with the police quickly, the very little evidence to go on, one investigator said they were, quote, shifting bricks and hoping something turns up. Known criminals were looked into and checks were made with
可能是预定目标，而玛格丽特和克莱尔只是在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。但凯也是一个受人尊敬、守法的当地人，没有敌人或邪恶的联系。这三名女性中的任何一个可能被专门针对的可能性根本说不通。在计算机出现之前的日子里，每一条信息都必须手工记录，然后相应地优先处理。警方很快就不堪重负。解决案件的压力很大，但由于几乎没有证据可循，一位调查人员说他们是在“搬砖，希望有什么东西出现”。已知的罪犯受到了调查，并与
psychiatric hospitals around Victoria, but no prime suspects emerged. An alert was placed on the check number stolen from the salon during the attack. If an attempt was made to cash the check, various banks were told to contact the authorities. An extensive search of the area surrounding the old London building came up dry, but dozens of knives were recovered across the Portland foreshore and surrounding bushes. Each was ruled out as the murder weapon, with investigators concluding they had most likely been thrown away or lost by fishermen. This wasn't unusual for a seaside town.
维多利亚州各地的精神病院进行了核对，但没有出现主要嫌疑人。警方对袭击期间从沙龙偷走的支票号码发出了警报。如果有人试图兑现支票，各银行被告知要联系当局。对老伦敦大楼周围地区的广泛搜查一无所获，但在波特兰前滩和周围的灌木丛中发现了数十把刀。每一把都被排除为凶器，调查人员得出结论，它们很可能是被渔民扔掉或丢失的。这对于一个海滨小镇来说并不罕见。
Portland Harbour was a busy space and commercial fishing was one of the towns main industries. The deep-sea port facilitated a direct link between the ports of Melbourne and Adelaide and was a hub for international shipping. It also paved the way for a growing drug problem in the local community. Investigators therefore considered the possibility that Claire and Margaret's killer could have come from one of the ships. On the day of the murders, only one ship was docked in the harbour, the M.V. Portland. Interestingly, the M.V. Portland had also been docked at the same time that Claire Acox encountered the so-called horrible man.
波特兰港是一个繁忙的空间，商业捕鱼是该镇的主要产业之一。深海港口促进了墨尔本和阿德莱德港口之间的直接联系，是国际航运的枢纽。它也为当地社区日益严重的毒品问题铺平了道路。因此，调查人员考虑了克莱尔和玛格丽特凶手可能来自其中一艘船的可能性。谋杀案发生当天，港口只有一艘船停靠，即“M.V.波特兰”号。有趣的是，“M.V.波特兰”号在克莱尔·艾科克遇到那个所谓的“可怕男人”时也停靠在同一时间。
The crew members were looked into, including their whereabouts on Friday, May 3. No obvious suspects emerged, but police couldn't discount the possibility that the harbor might have played a role. Yachts and small boats could dock in Portland Bay without any formal registration. It was therefore possible that a lone yachtsman or fishermen had stopped by Portland, committed the murders, and then sailed away without anyone attributing them to the area. One of Portland's other major industries was the local abattoir. At peak times, the abattoir employed upwards of a thousand staff. It wasn't unusual to see an off-duty abattoir worker walking around town with blood on their clothes.
船员们受到了调查，包括他们5月3日星期五的行踪。没有出现明显的嫌疑人，但警方不能排除港口可能发挥了作用的可能性。游艇和小船可以在没有正式登记的情况下停靠在波特兰湾。因此，一名孤独的游艇驾驶员或渔民可能在波特兰停留，犯下谋杀案，然后航行离开，而没有人将他们与该地区联系起来。波特兰的另一个主要产业是当地的屠宰场。在高峰期，屠宰场雇佣了上千名员工。看到一名下班的屠宰场工人穿着沾有血迹的衣服在镇上走动并不罕见。
The hairdresser murders could have been committed by an abattoir worker who was skilled with knives. Maybe he had a particular hatred of hairdressers or older women, or had simply snapped. Another theory was that the murders could have been retaliation. While neither Claire Acox nor Margaret Penny had any enemies, rumors swirled that someone might be out to get revenge on Claire's son, Constable Tim Acox. As a cop, he might have angered the wrong person through his line of work. There were whispers that Tim had been involved in a serious drug raid in the weeks before the murders. But Tim shut down the retaliation theory completely.
理发师谋杀案可能是由一名擅长用刀的屠宰场工人犯下的。也许他对理发师或老年女性有特别的仇恨，或者只是突然崩溃了。另一种理论是，谋杀案可能是报复。虽然克莱尔·艾科克和玛格丽特·彭尼都没有敌人，但有传言称有人可能想报复克莱尔的儿子，蒂姆·艾科克警员。作为一名警察，他可能在工作中得罪了错误的人。有传言称，蒂姆在谋杀案发生前几周参与了一次严重的毒品突袭。但蒂姆完全否认了报复理论。
He hadn't been involved in a drug bust or anything that would single him out. Tim was also married with an infant son. If someone was out to get him, it seemed strange that they'd target his mother and an inner and bystander. Investigators took the possibility of a grudge killing seriously and looked into the criminals Tim Aycock had crossed paths with on the job, but no tires were drawn. For one member of the Penny family, Margaret's death wasn't the first time their life had been affected by murder.
他没有参与毒品搜捕或任何会让他成为目标的事情。蒂姆也已婚，有一个婴儿儿子。如果有人要对付他，针对他的母亲和一个无辜的旁观者似乎很奇怪。调查人员认真对待了仇杀的可能性，并调查了蒂姆·艾科克在工作中遇到的罪犯，但没有发现任何线索。对于彭尼家族的一名成员来说，玛格丽特的死并不是他们第一次受到谋杀的影响。
Just eight months prior to the Portland slings, a couple had been murdered in a violent home invasion in the Victorian town of St. Andrews. Margaret's daughter Jacqueline was driving to her shift at a pub in St. Andrews when she passed the slain couples home. Oblivious to the horrors that had just taken place inside, Jacqueline noticed a red yoke go by. She recognised the driver as a customer who frequented the pub where she worked. When Jacqueline heard about the St. Andrews murders, she was reluctant to tell the police what she'd seen. The customer in the Red Ute was a heavy drug user who had an extensive criminal history. Jacqueline didn't want to get involved or be wrongly viewed as casting suspicion,
在波特兰惨案发生前仅八个月，一对夫妇在维多利亚州圣安德鲁斯（St. Andrews）镇的一起暴力入室抢劫案中被谋杀。玛格丽特的女儿杰奎琳在开车去圣安德鲁斯一家酒吧上班时，经过了这对被杀夫妇的家。对里面刚刚发生的恐怖事件一无所知，杰奎琳注意到一辆红色皮卡车经过。她认出司机是她工作酒吧的常客。当杰奎琳听说圣安德鲁斯的谋杀案时，她不愿告诉警方她所看到的情况。那辆红色皮卡车的司机是一个有大量犯罪记录的重度吸毒者。杰奎琳不想卷入其中，也不想被错误地视为在投下怀疑，
but she knew she had to do the right thing and eventually made a report. By the time Margaret Penny and Claire Aycock's were killed, the St. Andrew's murder remained unsolved, but the driver of the Red Ute was a prime suspect. Investigators considered whether Margaret Penny could have been targeted as revenge for her daughter cooperating with the police in relation to the St Andrew's case. They looked into it, but the suspect had a verified alibi for the time Margaret and Claire were killed. It seemed an unfortunate coincidence that Jacqueline's life had been touched by these events within such a short period of time, as the days turned to weeks with no arrests in the Portland
但她知道她必须做正确的事，最终做了一份报告。当玛格丽特·彭尼和克莱尔·艾科克被杀时，圣安德鲁斯的谋杀案仍然未破，但那辆红色皮卡车的司机是主要嫌疑人。调查人员考虑了玛格丽特·彭尼是否因为她的女儿在圣安德鲁斯案件中与警方合作而成为报复目标。他们对此进行了调查，但嫌疑人在玛格丽特和克莱尔被杀时有经过核实的不在场证明。杰奎琳的生活在如此短的时间内受到这些事件的影响，似乎是一个不幸的巧合。随着日子一天天过去，波特兰案件中没有逮捕任何人，
case, community fears heightened. The once laid-back town had changed overnight. Women became too afraid to leave their homes alone. Some were even too afraid to hang out the washing and avoided social events entirely. Many turned to self-defense classes, while others took their young children to stay elsewhere. Locals who once left their doors unlocked had security systems installed, with sales increasing tenfold. Portland's former mayor, Robert Menzel, told reporters, We all know one another. When somebody gets hurt, the whole town gets hurt. The host of a community radio station told listeners,
社区的恐惧加剧了。曾经悠闲的小镇一夜之间变了样。女性变得太害怕独自离开家。有些人甚至太害怕晾衣服，完全避免社交活动。许多人转向自卫课程，而另一些人则带孩子去别处居住。曾经不锁门的当地人安装了安全系统，销量增加了十倍。波特兰前市长罗伯特·门泽尔（Robert Menzel）告诉记者：“我们都认识彼此。当有人受伤时，整个城镇都会受伤。”一家社区广播电台的主持人告诉听众：
We must all realize that Portland has changed. The words, nothing happens in Portland, or it won't happen to me, are phrases that we can no longer afford to Wara. It was a sentiment shared at Claire Aycock's funeral. The priest overseeing her service told the gathering mourners, We can still barely believe it has happened. It leaves you numb and devastated. You ask yourself, why Portland?
“我们都必须意识到波特兰已经变了。‘波特兰什么都不会发生’或‘它不会发生在我身上’，这些话是我们再也负担不起的。”这种情绪在克莱尔·艾科克的葬礼上得到了共鸣。主持她葬礼的牧师告诉聚集的哀悼者：“我们仍然几乎不敢相信它已经发生了。它让你麻木和崩溃。你问自己，为什么是波特兰？”
Why then? Why at all? We are accustomed to such acts taking place in Chicago or New York, but now they have spread to our beautiful small city. For Claire's husband, Peter, mending the community spirit, was a priority. He told one investigator, Nothing we can do will bring Claire or Margaret back, but we can do a lot to put Portland back together.
“为什么是那时？为什么会发生？我们习惯于在芝加哥或纽约发生此类行为，但现在它们已经蔓延到我们美丽的城市。”对于克莱尔的丈夫彼得来说，修复社区精神是当务之急。他告诉一位调查人员：“我们所做的一切都无法让克莱尔或玛格丽特回来，但我们可以做很多事情来让波特兰恢复原状。”
Peter and Claire had loved their laid-back life in Portland. Peter believed the townsfolk were the best in Australia. But as the years ticked by, and his wife's murder remained unsolved, the town Peter so deeply cherished became a constant reminder of his torment and suffering. He relocated to Queensland but never stopped missing Claire for a second, telling the Warnable Standard newspaper. I still get into the car and sit there waiting for someone else to get in. By the time three years had passed with no breakthroughs in the case, the investigation was restarted from scratch.
彼得和克莱尔热爱他们在波特兰的悠闲生活。彼得认为镇民是澳大利亚最好的人。但随着岁月流逝，他妻子的谋杀案仍未破获，他深爱的城镇成了他痛苦和折磨的不断提醒。他搬到了昆士兰，但一秒钟也没有停止过对克莱尔的思念，他告诉《沃南布尔标准报》（Warnable Standard）：“我仍然会坐进车里，等着别人进来。”当案件在三年内没有任何突破时，调查从零开始重新启动。
The new detectives assigned to the case were eager to speak with Portland's former mayor, Robert Menzel. In the initial stages of the investigation, Robert had reported an incident that occurred on the afternoon of the murders. At around 441, Robert said he was driving past the old London Quifior when he noticed a man running from the direction of the rear courtyard. The man was carrying a small satchel and looked with. to be aged between 25 and 30 years old. Robert stopped his car at the pedestrian crossing. The man raced directly by, continuing past the nearby Richmond Henty Hotel and then onto the foreshore until Robert lost sight of him.
被分配到该案的新侦探急于与波特兰前市长罗伯特·门泽尔交谈。在调查的初期阶段，罗伯特报告了谋杀案当天下午发生的一起事件。下午4点41分左右，罗伯特说他开车经过老伦敦美发沙龙时，注意到一名男子从后院方向跑出来。该男子背着一个小挎包，看起来年龄在25到30岁之间。罗伯特在人行横道上停下了车。那名男子直接跑过，继续经过附近的里士满亨蒂酒店（Richmond Henty Hotel），然后跑向海滩，直到罗伯特失去了他的踪影。
At the time, the police had mostly palmed this siding off because Robert hadn't noticed any blood on the running man. The time of the siding was also questionable. By 4.41 p.m., Claire and Margaret's bodies had already been discovered. Police were more interested in the sightings that occurred within the crucial 90-minute window between 305 and 4.30 p.m. With the passing of time, detectives were curious to know more about this sighting. Formerly interviewed for the first time, Robert Menzel said the report was wrong. He'd actually seen the running man sometime between 3.30 and 4pm. Robert still remembered what the man looked like.
当时，警方大多因为罗伯特没有注意到跑步的男子身上有任何血迹而忽略了这一目击事件。目击的时间也值得怀疑。到下午4点41分，克莱尔和玛格丽特的尸体已经被发现。警方对下午3点05分到4点30分之间关键的90分钟窗口内发生的目击事件更感兴趣。随着时间的推移，侦探们很想了解更多关于这次目击的信息。罗伯特·门泽尔第一次接受正式采访时说，之前的报告是错误的。他实际上是在下午3点30分到4点之间的某个时间看到那个跑步的男子的。罗伯特仍然记得那个男人的样子。
He was approximately 170 centimetres tall and of medium build. He was white with a fair complexion, collar-length dark hair, and wearing dark-rimmed round glasses. Robert helped create a photofit sketch which was released to the public. Despite a long-standing $100,000 reward for information, no one was able to identify the running man. By 1995, approximately 5,000 people had been interviewed in relation to the double homicide, yet not a single arrest was made. 22 witnesses were called during a one-day inquest into the murders of Margaret and Claire, but the coroner was unable to identify a motive or a suspect.
他身高约170厘米，中等身材。他是白人，肤色白皙，留着领口长度的深色头发，戴着深色圆框眼镜。罗伯特协助绘制了一张拼图，并向公众发布。尽管悬赏10万美元征集线索已久，但仍无人能认出那个奔跑的男子。到1995年，已有约5000人因这起双重谋杀案接受了问询，但没有一人被捕。在针对玛格丽特和克莱尔谋杀案为期一天的死因研讯中，共有22名证人出庭，但验尸官未能确定动机或嫌疑人。
They simply concluded that the two women had been stabbed to death by a person unknown. Our former Portland resident named Megan was living in Canada when she heard about the result of the inquest. She obtained a copy of the Running Man sketch and as soon as she laid eyes on the bespectacled face that triggered a memory. On Friday, May 3, 1991, Megan had been walking her dog about 300 metres from the old London building. In a street behind the Richmond Henty Hotel, she crossed paths with a bed. footman who stopped to pat her dog. As he did so, Megan noticed that the man had what appeared to be bloodstains wiped on his jeans. When Megan heard that two women had been murdered nearby, she called the police to report the sighting, but never received a response.
他们最终的结论仅仅是，这两名女性被一名身份不明的人刺死。我们以前住在波特兰的一位名叫梅根的居民，在加拿大听说了研讯结果。她获得了一份“奔跑男子”的拼图，当她看到那张戴眼镜的脸时，一段记忆被唤醒了。1991年5月3日星期五，梅根在离伦敦老建筑约300米的地方遛狗。在里士满亨蒂酒店后面的一条街上，她与一名赤脚男子擦肩而过，那人停下来拍了拍她的狗。就在那时，梅根注意到那人的牛仔裤上似乎有血迹。当梅根听说附近有两名女性被杀时，她打电话给警察报告了这一发现，但从未得到回应。
She therefore assumed the sighting wasn't significant. But looking at the suspect sketch created by Robert Menzel, Megan was certain they had both seen the same man. She contacted the authorities in Australia who showed her a photo line-up of potential suspects. Given the amount of time that had passed, Megan couldn't identify any of the individuals with certainty. Investigators weren't entirely sure what to make of Megan's statement. Moments after her encounter with the barefoot man, Megan said she saw police. and paramedics gathered outside of the old London coiffure. Investigators ultimately concluded that her encounter had occurred too late in the sequence of
因此，她认为这次目击并不重要。但看着罗伯特·门泽尔绘制的嫌疑人拼图，梅根确信他们看到的都是同一个人。她联系了澳大利亚当局，对方给她看了潜在嫌疑人的照片排查。由于时间已经过去很久，梅根无法确定地认出其中任何一个人。调查人员并不确定该如何看待梅根的陈述。梅根说，在她遇到赤脚男子后不久，她看到警察和医护人员聚集在伦敦老理发店外。调查人员最终得出结论，她的遭遇发生在事件序列中太靠后的时间点，
events to hold significance. It was also possible that her memory had been influenced over time. Given the varying times of Robert Menzel's account, investigators ultimately doubted the running man was involved with the killings. Regardless, this mystery man was still of interest. Having been around the area at the time the crime occurred, it was possible he held crucial information. And he wasn't the only one. Gordon Smith had grown up in Portland. He'd been an outgoing student and a confident athlete until his late teens when he accepted an apprenticeship with the army. Within two years, a significant change in Gordon's behaviour led to him being diagnosed with schizophrenia and depression.
因此不具备重要意义。她的记忆也可能随着时间的推移受到了影响。鉴于罗伯特·门泽尔的陈述时间存在差异，调查人员最终怀疑“奔跑男子”是否与这起杀人案有关。无论如何，这个神秘男子仍然引起了关注。由于他在案发时就在附近，他可能掌握着关键信息。而且他并不是唯一一个。戈登·史密斯在波特兰长大。他曾是一名外向的学生和自信的运动员，直到十几岁后期，他接受了军队的学徒培训。两年内，戈登的行为发生了重大变化，导致他被诊断出患有精神分裂症和抑郁症。
He was medically discharged and spent the next few years struggling to accept his diagnosis. Gordon turned to drugs to cope. This interfered with his medication and led to further behavioural changes. Gordon's family noted that he could become withdrawn, uptight and aggressive. At 2.40 on the afternoon that Claire Aycock's and Margaret Penny were killed, an old classmate of Gordon's had spotted the then-25-year-old about 200 metres from the old London. He appeared to be mildly drug-affected. The police were made aware of Gordon Smith's presence near the crime scene,
他因病退伍，并在接下来的几年里努力接受自己的诊断。戈登开始靠毒品来应对。这干扰了他的药物治疗，并导致了进一步的行为改变。戈登的家人注意到他变得孤僻、紧张且具有攻击性。在克莱尔·艾科克斯和玛格丽特·彭尼被杀的那天下午2点40分，戈登的一位老同学在离伦敦老建筑约200米处看到了当时25岁的他。他看起来轻微受到了毒品的影响。警方获悉了戈登·史密斯在犯罪现场附近出现的情况，
not because he was particularly suspicious, but in case he witnessed something of interest. They knew he couldn't be the horrible man that Claire Aycock had encountered. Claire and Gordon knew one another and she knew. would have easily identified him when telling her friends about the experience. When questioned, Gordon gave vague answers. He couldn't give an exact time for his movements, only saying that he'd walked the two and a half kilometers home and fallen asleep. With no one to verify Gordon's alibi, he remained a person of interest, but there was never anything to definitively tie him to the crime. Then in April, 1998, came to.
并不是因为他特别可疑，而是以防他目击了什么有价值的东西。他们知道他不可能就是克莱尔·艾科克斯遇到的那个可怕的男人。克莱尔和戈登认识，如果克莱尔在向朋友讲述那次经历时，肯定会轻易认出他。在接受问询时，戈登回答得含糊其辞。他无法给出自己行踪的确切时间，只说他走了两公里半回家并睡着了。由于没有人能证实戈登的不在场证明，他仍然是一个相关人员，但从未有任何证据能将他与这起犯罪明确联系起来。然后到了1998年4月，出现了一个
an unexpected revelation. The now 32-year-old Gordon had always been close with his cousin, Russell Smith. The two were the same age and had both gravitated towards drugs in their adult years. While they'd always looked out for each other, with almost seven years passing since Claire Aycock's and Margaret Penny were killed, Russell had something he wanted to get off his chest. Russell contacted police and told them that on the day after the attack at the old London Quifur, he received a phone call from Gordon. Gordon allegedly confessed that he was responsible for the attack at the hair salon
意想不到的披露。现年32岁的戈登一直与他的堂兄拉塞尔·史密斯关系密切。两人同龄，成年后都沉迷于毒品。虽然他们一直互相照应，但距离克莱尔·艾科克斯和玛格丽特·彭尼被杀已经过去了近七年，拉塞尔有些话想一吐为快。拉塞尔联系了警方，告诉他们，在伦敦老理发店袭击事件发生的第二天，他接到了戈登的电话。戈登据称承认他对理发店的袭击负责，
and needed help disposing of his blood-stained clothing. Russell lived in Melbourne at the time, but travelled straight to Portland and allegedly helped his cousin throw the evidence off a cliff and out to sea. The police were wary of Russell's claims. He had an extensive criminal history of his own, and it was possible he was making the story up in the hopes of securing a lighter sentence for unrelated charges. Regardless, his report was taken seriously.
并需要帮助处理他沾满血迹的衣服。拉塞尔当时住在墨尔本，但他直接前往波特兰，据称帮助他的堂弟将证据扔下悬崖，抛入大海。警方对拉塞尔的说法持怀疑态度。他自己有大量的犯罪记录，而且他有可能是在编造故事，希望以此换取无关指控的较轻判决。无论如何，他的报告还是受到了重视。
Gordon Smith was put under the microscope. Further attempts to verify his alibi continued to fail, and no incriminating evidence surfaced. Despite some drug-related charges, he still had no criminal convictions. It was possible that Gordon Smith had been viewed suspiciously due to his mental health issues and drug use. Police also considered whether Russell Smith was involved in the murders and was throwing his cousin under the bus to deflect attention from himself.
戈登·史密斯被置于显微镜下审视。进一步核实他不在场证明的尝试继续失败，也没有出现任何确凿的证据。尽管有一些与毒品有关的指控，但他仍然没有刑事定罪。戈登·史密斯可能仅仅因为他的心理健康问题和吸毒史而被怀疑。警方还考虑了拉塞尔·史密斯是否参与了谋杀，并试图通过将他的堂弟推出来转移对自己的注意力。
Russell had a rap sheet dating back to his teenage years, including a jail sentence for his participation in the unprovoked fatal group bashing of a 46-year-old man. He too suffered from various mental health issues exacerbated by illicit drug use. Whatever the truth, the renewed police interest took a toll on Gordon Smith. In the wake of the hairdresser murders, the initial public scrutiny had fuelled his paranoia. Under scrutiny again seven years later, Gordon, mental health suffered, and in June he moved to Melbourne to stay with a relative. Ten days later, the caretaker at a city church found Gordon's body hanging from inside the cathedral.
拉塞尔从十几岁起就有犯罪记录，包括因参与一起无端致命的群体殴打一名46岁男子的案件而被判入狱。他也患有各种心理健康问题，并因非法使用毒品而加剧。无论真相如何，警方重新燃起的兴趣对戈登·史密斯造成了打击。在理发师谋杀案发生后，最初的公众审视加剧了他的偏执。七年后再次受到审视，戈登的心理健康状况恶化，六月他搬到墨尔本与亲戚同住。十天后，一位城市教堂的看守人发现戈登的尸体悬挂在教堂内。
He didn't leave a suicide note. By September 1998, Russell Smith was being held in remand for various offences. Days after his 33rd birthday, he used a shoelace to hang himself from the bunk bed of his cell. With that, the inquiries into both men reached an inconclusive end. Former journalist-turned-school teacher Leonie Wallace had been fascinated by the Portland murders ever since she heard about the case in 1991. As the years continued to tick by with no resolution to the case, Leone started researching the crime herself. She spent years gathering information and interviewing investigators, family members and townsfolk. Her hard work led to the 2012 publication of a comprehensive book titled Horrible Man,
他没有留下遗书。到1998年9月，拉塞尔·史密斯因各种罪行被还押候审。在他33岁生日几天后，他用鞋带在牢房的双层床上上吊自杀。至此，对这两名男子的调查以无果告终。前记者转行的学校教师利奥妮·华莱士自1991年听说这起案件以来，一直对波特兰谋杀案着迷。随着岁月流逝，案件仍未解决，利奥妮开始亲自研究这起犯罪。她花了数年时间收集信息，采访调查人员、家庭成员和镇民。她的努力促成了2012年出版的一本名为《可怕的男人》的综合性书籍，
which publicly revealed intricate details about the hairdresser murders for the very first time. Leone hoped the book might compel someone with information to come forward and finally get some resolution for the families. During her inquiries, Leone received a text message from a mysterious source who claimed, I know who killed those two women. I have a story that has never been told. The sender then seemingly had a change of heart and went silent. When Leone finally managed to get through to them, she found it was a woman.
该书首次公开披露了理发师谋杀案的复杂细节。利奥妮希望这本书能促使知情者挺身而出，最终为受害者家属讨回公道。在调查期间，利奥妮收到了一条来自神秘来源的短信，声称：“我知道是谁杀了那两个女人。我有一个从未被讲述过的故事。”发件人随后似乎改变了主意，变得沉默不语。当利奥妮最终设法联系上他们时，发现对方是一名女性。
The woman said she was concerned about the repercussions of speaking. up and no longer wanted to discuss it. Whether the woman had a genuine lead remains unknown, but either way, the publication of horrible man propelled the case back into the news and led to renewed public interest. In 2013, the investigation into the murders of Claire Aycock's and Margaret Penny was reopened once again. With fresh eyes, new investigators trawled through the available evidence and thousands of reports on file. The more they learned, it became clear that one particular individual had been curiously overlooked. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this
这名女子说她担心说出来的后果，不想再讨论这件事了。这名女子是否掌握真正的线索尚不得而知，但无论如何，《可怕的男人》的出版将案件重新带回了新闻视野，并引发了公众的重新关注。2013年，针对克莱尔·艾科克斯和玛格丽特·彭尼谋杀案的调查再次重启。带着新的视角，新的调查人员仔细梳理了现有证据和档案中的数千份报告。他们了解得越多，就越清楚有一个特定的人被奇怪地忽视了。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本
episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Within days of the Portland Hair Salon murders, the husbands of both Claire and Margaret had been ruled out as suspects. Peter Aycock's and Robert Penny had confirmed alibis and there was no evidence implicating either of the men in the crimes. Both claimed that their marriages were loving and stable. However, as the new investigators looking at the case in 2013 discovered, this wasn't necessarily true. The pennies had two adult children, a daughter named Jacqueline and a son named Anthony. In the wake of the crimes, Anthony was tormented.
节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。在波特兰理发店谋杀案发生后的几天内，克莱尔和玛格丽特的丈夫都被排除了嫌疑。彼得·艾科克斯和罗伯特·彭尼都有确凿的不在场证明，也没有证据表明这两人与犯罪有关。两人都声称他们的婚姻充满爱且稳定。然而，正如2013年调查该案的新调查人员所发现的那样，事实并非一定如此。彭尼夫妇有两个成年子女，女儿名叫杰奎琳，儿子名叫安东尼。在犯罪发生后，安东尼备受折磨。
While he never witnessed any violence between his parents, he recalled that their marriage was particularly volatile. When Anthony was growing up, Margaret and Robert argued often. His mother had once confided in him that Robert had, quote, beaten her black and blue. Anthony was also aware that his father had cheated on his mother at least once. At the time of the murders, Anthony was living overseas. While he wasn't aware of any problems in his parents' marriage, he felt that his mother was unhappy. Every time Anthony spoke to Margaret, she mentioned feeling alone and isolated. But it wasn't just this past behaviour that concerned Anthony.
虽然他从未目睹父母之间的任何暴力行为，但他回忆说他们的婚姻特别不稳定。安东尼在成长过程中，玛格丽特和罗伯特经常争吵。他的母亲曾向他吐露，罗伯特曾“把她打得青一块紫一块”。安东尼还知道他的父亲至少有一次背叛了他的母亲。在谋杀案发生时，安东尼住在海外。虽然他不知道父母婚姻中存在任何问题，但他觉得母亲很不快乐。安东尼每次与玛格丽特交谈，她都会提到感到孤独和孤立。但让安东尼担心的不仅仅是这些过去的行为。
After Margaret and Claire were murdered, Robert Penny told the police that he didn't have access to a car at the time the crime was committed. The couple shared a vehicle and Margaret had taken it to her hair appointment. But this wasn't true. While Anthony was overseas, he'd left his car with his parents, urging them to drive it whenever they needed. Back in 1991, Anthony called Claire Aycock's son. Constable Tim Aycock to get this information off his chest. Tim reported it to the original investigators working on the case, but they saw no reason to suspect Robert Penny. For starters, at the time of the murders, Robert was a 59-year-old retiree with an unblemished record. It didn't seem likely that he was
在玛格丽特和克莱尔被谋杀后，罗伯特·彭尼告诉警方，他在犯罪发生时无法使用汽车。这对夫妇共用一辆车，而玛格丽特开着它去参加理发预约了。但这并不是真的。当安东尼在海外时，他把车留给了父母，敦促他们在需要时随时驾驶。1991年，安东尼打电话给克莱尔·艾科克斯的儿子、警员蒂姆·艾科克斯，想把这些信息说出来。蒂姆向负责此案的原始调查人员报告了此事，但他们认为没有理由怀疑罗伯特·彭尼。首先，在谋杀案发生时，罗伯特是一位59岁的退休人员，记录清白。他看起来不太可能
capable of pulling off such a violent and frenzied attack, especially while taking care of his 5-year-old granddaughter. Secondly, Robert Penny was known around Portland. It seemed absurd to think that he could have driven to the middle of town on a busy afternoon, committed the brutal crime, and then gone straight home without attracting any attention. One detective remarked, If you're going to kill a member of your family, you wouldn't do it in the middle of the afternoon. You'd do it in the confines of your own home and concoct a story or accident or or a otherwise. A search of the Penny's home after the bodies were discovered hadn't uncovered any blood or anything else incriminating. Furthermore, when Margaret's friend Shirley Endersby had called
有能力实施如此暴力和疯狂的袭击，尤其是在照顾他5岁的孙女时。其次，罗伯特·彭尼在波特兰很有名。认为他可以在一个繁忙的下午开车到市中心，实施残酷的犯罪，然后直接回家而不引起任何注意，这似乎很荒谬。一位侦探评论道：“如果你要杀害你的家庭成员，你不会在下午大白天做。你会选择在自己家中，并编造一个事故或其他故事。”在发现尸体后对彭尼家的搜查并没有发现任何血迹或其他任何有罪的证据。此外，当玛格丽特的朋友雪莉·恩德斯比在下午4点左右打电话
the Penny's home looking for Margaret at around 4pm, Robert had answered the phone. This proved he was home during at least some of the crucial 90-minute time frame in which the murders were believed to have occurred. But the couple's son wasn't the only one with suspicions. One of Robert Penny's nephews had also called the police in 1992 to suggest they look into Robert more closely. During his working years, Robert had been the managing director of a successful car park company. This led to him and Margaret temporarily living in Southeast Asia. According to the Penny's nephew, Robert had shady business dealings and some, quote, skeletons in his closet from over the
到彭尼家找玛格丽特时，是罗伯特接的电话。这证明他在被认为发生谋杀案的关键90分钟时间框架内，至少有一部分时间是在家的。但这对夫妇的儿子并不是唯一一个有怀疑的人。罗伯特·彭尼的一位侄子也在1992年打电话给警方，建议他们更仔细地调查罗伯特。在工作期间，罗伯特曾是一家成功的停车场公司的总经理。这导致他和玛格丽特曾暂时居住在东南亚。据彭尼的侄子说，罗伯特有不正当的商业往来，并且在海外有一些“不可告人的秘密”。
Seas. Additionally, questions had been raised about Robert's behaviour following Margaret's death. Some believed that he didn't grieve appropriately. In their view, he seemed to be handling things incredibly well for someone whose wife had just been killed so brutally. The owner of a Portland general store told 60 minutes that on the weekend after the murders, Robert Penny came into his store. He was in a jovial mood and allegedly asked for something that could help remove blood stains. The shop owner found Robert's behaviour so unusual that he called the police to report the encounter, but they never followed him up. Investigators ended up interviewing Robert Penny in 1993 and didn't uncover anything tying him to the murders.
此外，关于罗伯特在玛格丽特死后的行为也引发了质疑。一些人认为他没有表现出适当的悲伤。在他们看来，对于一个妻子刚刚被如此残忍杀害的人来说，他处理事情的方式似乎好得令人难以置信。一家波特兰杂货店的老板告诉《60分钟》节目，在谋杀案发生后的那个周末，罗伯特·彭尼进了他的店。他心情愉快，据称询问了有什么东西可以帮助去除血迹。店主觉得罗伯特的行为太反常了，于是打电话给警察报告了这次遭遇，但他们从未跟进。调查人员最终在1993年问询了罗伯特·彭尼，但没有发现任何将他与谋杀案联系起来的证据。
Regardless, suspicions remained and were heightened further when Robert chose not to attend the inquest in 1995. While Robert Penny might not have killed Margaret and Claire himself, some wondered whether it was possible he'd hired someone to do the deed on his behalf. For Margaret and Robert's daughter Jacqueline, having her life touched by murder twice within an eight-month time span took its toll. Months after her mother was killed, Jacqueline still held concerns about being a potential witness to the St. Andrews case.
无论如何，怀疑依然存在，并且在罗伯特选择不参加1995年的死因研讯时进一步加剧。虽然罗伯特·彭尼可能没有亲自杀害玛格丽特和克莱尔，但有些人怀疑他是否可能雇佣了某人代他行凶。对于玛格丽特和罗伯特的女儿杰奎琳来说，在八个月内两次受到谋杀案的影响，让她付出了沉重的代价。在母亲被杀几个月后，杰奎琳仍然担心自己会成为圣安德鲁斯案件的潜在证人。
She wondered whether her mother was killed. mother could have been targeted as a message to keep Jacqueline quiet about the individual in the red Ute she saw near the scene. Jacqueline told her father that she feared for the safety of her own family. According to Jacqueline, Robert Penny turned to her and said, Well, why don't we just get him hit? Referring to the suspect in the red Ute. Jacqueline was shocked.
她怀疑她的母亲是否被当作一个目标，以此作为警告，让杰奎琳对她在现场附近看到的红色皮卡车里的人保持沉默。杰奎琳告诉她的父亲，她担心自己家人的安全。据杰奎琳说，罗伯特·彭尼转向她说：“好吧，我们为什么不直接雇人干掉他？”指的是红色皮卡车里的嫌疑人。杰奎琳感到震惊。
She told her dad she didn't know how to do such a thing. Robert allegedly responded, Well, I do. From that point on, Jacqueline suspected that her father was involved in her mother's death. Four years after the murders, Jacqueline attended a seance with some friends. She asked the guiding spirit who was responsible for killing her mother. The response was that her father had paid a hitman named Graham $20,000 to get rid of his wife so he could be with another woman. Unlike Peter Aycock's, who never remarried following Claire's
她告诉父亲她不知道该怎么做这种事。罗伯特据称回答说：“好吧，我知道。”从那时起，杰奎琳怀疑她的父亲参与了她母亲的死亡。谋杀案发生四年后，杰奎琳和一些朋友参加了一场降神会。她问引导灵是谁负责杀害她的母亲。得到的回答是，她的父亲付给了一个名叫格雷厄姆的杀手2万美元来除掉他的妻子，这样他就可以和另一个女人在一起。与彼得·艾科克斯不同，他在克莱尔死后从未再婚，
death, Robert Penny moved on quickly. Within just months of Margaret's murder, Robert moved in with a family friend named Kim. The two soon entered a romantic relationship and were married in September of 1992. Robert vehemently denied that he'd had an affair while Margaret was still alive. He claimed that Kim had comforted him in the wake of Margaret's death, and a relationship blossomed from there. But one of Kim's neighbours claimed to have seen some affection between Robert and Kim as early as April 1991, the month before Margaret was killed. The exact date that Robert and Kim became intimate was unclear, but the speed at which Robert remarried definitely raised some eyebrows. It also added further weight to some strange comments that Robert had made shortly after his wife's death.
罗伯特·彭尼很快就走出了阴影。在玛格丽特被谋杀仅几个月后，罗伯特就与一位名叫金的家庭朋友住在一起。两人很快开始了浪漫关系，并于1992年9月结婚。罗伯特强烈否认他在玛格丽特还活着时有外遇。他声称金在玛格丽特死后安慰了他，两人之间的关系由此萌芽。但金的一位邻居声称早在1991年4月，即玛格丽特被杀的前一个月，就看到罗伯特和金之间有亲密举动。罗伯特和金开始亲密关系的具体日期尚不清楚，但罗伯特再婚的速度确实引起了一些人的怀疑。这也为罗伯特在妻子死后不久所说的一些奇怪言论增加了分量。
Whoever had killed Claire Aycox and Margaret Penny had done so with a knife. However, they'd also used a smaller, narrow object to inflict puncture wounds into Margaret's back and chest. This object had never been identified, but police had considered the possibility that it could have been either a pair of scissors or a tail comb. Used by hairdressers, a tail comb is a plastic comb with a tapered metal handle. The metal portion is used to separate and part hair for styling, and it has a sharp tip that could potentially pierce through skin. One such comb had been found on one of the chairs in the shampoo room at the old London coiffure, but the pathologists who conducted Margaret's autopsy were ultimately unable to determine
无论谁杀害了克莱尔·艾科克斯和玛格丽特·彭尼，都是用刀做的。然而，他们还使用了一个较小的、细长的物体在玛格丽特的背部和胸部造成了穿刺伤。这个物体从未被确认，但警方曾考虑过它可能是剪刀或尾梳的可能性。理发师使用的尾梳是一种带有锥形金属手柄的塑料梳子。金属部分用于在造型时分离和分发头发，它有一个尖锐的尖端，有可能刺穿皮肤。在伦敦老理发店洗发室的一张椅子上发现了一把这样的梳子，但对玛格丽特进行尸检的病理学家最终无法确定
what caused the puncture marks to her body. Police had made no mention of the comb when breaking the news of the murders to Robert Penny or Peter Aycock's. However, when Robert told Jacqueline that her mother had been killed, he allegedly said that a knife and a hair comb were used. He then allegedly told his son that the killer had used a knife, scissors and at the sharp end of a metal comb. Robert made a similar comment when visiting Peter Aycock shortly after, while also saying something along the lines of, at least Claire died very quickly. This raised the question,
是什么导致了她身体上的穿刺痕迹。警方在向罗伯特·彭尼或彼得·艾科克斯通报谋杀案消息时，没有提到梳子。然而，当罗伯特告诉杰奎琳她的母亲被杀时，他据称说使用了刀和发梳。他随后据称告诉他的儿子，凶手使用了刀、剪刀和金属梳子的尖端。罗伯特在不久后拜访彼得·艾科克斯时也发表了类似的评论，同时还说了类似“至少克莱尔死得很快”的话。这引发了一个问题：
how could Robert Penny have known these things unless he was directly involved with the crime? Robert's alibi for the time of the crime was that he was at home making a swing with his five-year-old granddaughter, Alice. By the time investigators re-examined the case in 2013, Alice was aged in her early 20s. She provided a statement for the first time, recalling that on the afternoon of Friday, May 3, 1991, Margaret had tried to take her to the hair salon. Robert disagreed and an argument ensued, with the couple fighting over Alice like a tug of war.
罗伯特·彭尼怎么可能知道这些事情，除非他直接参与了犯罪？罗伯特对犯罪时间的不在场证明是他当时在家和5岁的孙女爱丽丝一起做秋千。到2013年调查人员重新审查此案时，爱丽丝已经20出头了。她第一次提供了陈述，回忆说在1991年5月3日星期五下午，玛格丽特曾试图带她去理发店。罗伯特不同意，随后发生了争吵，两人像拔河一样争夺爱丽丝。
Given that two decades had passed, investigators weren't sure how much weight to put on this statement. But if there was any truth to it, it implied that Robert had fought to keep his granddaughter at home that day because he knew what horrors were about to unfold at the salon. What if he had hired a hitman after all? It would explain why Margaret had received more injuries than Claire. Perhaps a contract killer had snuck into the salon while Claire had ducked out to grab the knitting from her car. They might have only intended to kill Margaret, not realizing that Claire would be back so soon. With the suspicious elements stacking up against Robert Penny, the decision was made to place covert listening devices in his home and on his phone.
鉴于已经过去了二十年，调查人员不确定该对这份陈述给予多大的权重。但如果其中有任何真实成分，这意味着罗伯特那天努力把孙女留在家里，因为他知道理发店即将发生什么恐怖事件。如果他真的雇佣了杀手呢？这可以解释为什么玛格丽特受到的伤害比克莱尔多。也许职业杀手在克莱尔溜出去从车里拿针织品时溜进了理发店。他们可能只打算杀害玛格丽特，没意识到克莱尔会这么快回来。随着针对罗伯特·彭尼的怀疑因素不断增加，警方决定在他的家中和电话上安装秘密监听设备。
Several attempts were made to engage Robert in conversations that might lead him to reveal something incriminating. But he didn't say a single word that implied any level of guilt. In 2014, Robert Penny voluntarily agreed to a series of police interviews. He had admitted he'd been unfaithful to Margaret while they were living overseas, but strongly denied having an affair leading up to her death. Robert outright rejected claims there had been any animosity between the couple in 1991, saying that he loved his wife dearly and was devastated by her death. He acknowledged that his marriage to Kim happened quickly,
警方多次尝试引导罗伯特进行可能导致他透露罪证的对话。但他没有说出一句暗示任何程度内疚的话。2014年，罗伯特·彭尼自愿同意接受一系列警方问询。他承认在他们住在海外时对玛格丽特不忠，但强烈否认在玛格丽特死前有外遇。罗伯特断然拒绝了关于1991年这对夫妇之间存在任何敌意的说法，称他深爱着他的妻子，并对她的死感到悲痛欲绝。他承认他与金的婚姻发生得很快，
but explained that his minister had advised him to get on with his life and put himself back together. The interviewing detectives asked how Robert could have possibly known that a tail comb was potentially used during the attack. He said he couldn't remember, but that he'd possibly been told by someone or had arrived at the conclusion himself. As for the alleged comments about hiring a hitman, Robert flat out denied this, saying, I didn't know any bloody hitman.
但解释说他的牧师建议他继续生活，重新振作起来。负责问询的侦探询问罗伯特怎么可能知道袭击中可能使用了尾梳。他说他不记得了，但可能是别人告诉他的，或者他自己得出了这个结论。至于关于雇佣杀手的所谓评论，罗伯特断然否认，说：“我不认识什么该死的杀手。”
He urged investigators to check his bank statements if they didn't believe him, saying he had never associated with outlaws. When asked if he was involved with Margaret's death in any way, Robert became exasperated. He questioned how, anyone could think he had a motive for killing his wife, saying, We had a wonderful 36 years. Christ, it's abhorrent to me.
他敦促调查人员检查他的银行对账单，如果他们不相信他，说他从未与不法分子交往过。当被问及他是否以任何方式参与了玛格丽特的死亡时，罗伯特变得愤怒。他质疑怎么会有人认为他有杀妻的动机，说：“我们度过了美好的36年。天哪，这对我来说是令人厌恶的。”
The answer is no. There's no way in the world. My conscience is completely clear. By 2015, Robert Penny was 83 years old and living in Melbourne. Given his age, investigators knew that time was of the essence. Although they didn't have any physically. evidence tying Robert to the double murder, the circumstantial evidence mounted to a point that the decision was made to place him under arrest. In April 2015, almost 24 years after the fact,
“答案是否定的。绝无可能。我的良心完全清白。”到2015年，罗伯特·彭尼已经83岁，住在墨尔本。鉴于他的年龄，调查人员知道时间至关重要。尽管他们没有任何将罗伯特与这起双重谋杀案联系起来的物证，但间接证据积累到了一定程度，警方决定将他逮捕。2015年4月，在案发近24年后，
Robert Penny was formally charged with the murders of Margaret Penny and Claire Aycock. Seven months later, a committal hearing was held with 50 witnesses scheduled to give evidence. However, on the first day, something happened that turned the case against Robert Penny on its head. One of the major pieces of physical evidence that had been taken from the old London Quiffure crime scene was a piece of tissue paper. It had been found next to the tail comb on a chair in the shampoo room and was lightly stained with blood. In the early days of the investigation, DNA technology was in its infancy. But recent advances had revealed that the tissue paper returned three DNA profiles, Margaret Penny's, Claire Acoxes, and the partial profile of an unknown male.
罗伯特·彭尼被正式指控谋杀玛格丽特·彭尼和克莱尔·艾科克斯。七个月后，举行了预审听证会，原定有50名证人出庭作证。然而，在第一天，发生了一件事，使案件对罗伯特·彭尼的指控发生了逆转。从伦敦老理发店犯罪现场提取的主要物证之一是一张纸巾。它是在洗发室椅子上的尾梳旁边发现的，上面有轻微的血迹。在调查初期，DNA技术还处于起步阶段。但最近的进展显示，纸巾上提取出了三个DNA图谱：玛格丽特·彭尼的、克莱尔·艾科克斯的，以及一个未知男性的部分图谱。
The partial profile was compared against several persons of interest in the Portland case, including Robert Penny. There were no matches. Presented with this information, the magistrate overseeing Robert's committal hearing adjourned the proceeding to give the prosecution an opportunity to reassess their case. The fact that no match was identified didn't necessarily eliminate anyone from the investigation. The scope of the testing was limited given it was only a partial profile, and there was nothing to definitively confirm that the profile had come from the offender. Regardless, it weakened the prosecution's argument significantly.
该部分图谱与波特兰案件中的几名相关人员进行了比对，包括罗伯特·彭尼。没有匹配结果。在获悉这一信息后，负责罗伯特预审听证会的裁判官休庭，以便让检方有机会重新评估他们的案件。没有发现匹配结果并不一定能将任何人排除在调查之外。由于只是部分图谱，测试范围有限，而且没有任何证据能明确证实该图谱来自犯罪者。无论如何，这大大削弱了检方的论点。
The hearing was rescheduled for May the following. year, but it never went ahead. In March 2016, Robert Penny passed away from natural causes. Some assumed this meant the case was closed, but as Robert's lawyer pointed out, his client had died an innocent man. A police spokesperson said, this investigation remains active and the Victoria Police Homicide Squad is committed to finding the person or persons responsible for these deaths. A request was approved for a new inquest to be held into the deaths of Claire Aycock's and Margaret Penny. Unlike the original inquest conducted in 1995, which only lasted one day, the 2016 inquest was comprehensive. Over 10 days, 28 witnesses were called to give evidence, as the coroner went over thousands of pages of official reports and investigative notes.
听证会重新安排在次年5月，但从未进行。2016年3月，罗伯特·彭尼因自然原因去世。一些人认为这意味着案件已经结案，但正如罗伯特的律师所指出的，他的当事人是清白地死去的。警方发言人表示：“此项调查仍然活跃，维多利亚州警方凶杀组致力于寻找对这些死亡负责的人。”一项关于对克莱尔·艾科克斯和玛格丽特·彭尼的死亡进行新死因研讯的请求获得批准。与1995年仅持续一天的原始研讯不同，2016年的研讯非常全面。在10天的时间里，28名证人被传唤作证，验尸官审阅了数千页的官方报告和调查笔记。
Robert Penny's comments about the tail comb were a major focus. First and foremost, the coroner wanted to establish whether a tail comb could have actually caused the injuries inflicted on Margaret Penny's torso. The forensic pathologist who attended the crime scene back in 1991 said the wounds hadn't penetrated deep enough to determine what type of weapon had been used. Whatever it was, he was of the opinion that the tail comb found in the shampoo room wasn't a match. However, an expert from the United Kingdom studied Margaret's injuries and determined that a tail comb was a, quote, possible and plausible explanation for the unusual injuries.
罗伯特·彭尼关于尾梳的评论是一个主要焦点。首先，验尸官想确定尾梳是否真的能造成玛格丽特·彭尼躯干上的伤害。1991年到达犯罪现场的法医病理学家表示，伤口穿透深度不足以确定使用了何种武器。无论是什么，他的观点是洗发室里发现的尾梳并不匹配。然而，来自英国的一位专家研究了玛格丽特的伤口，并确定尾梳是一个“可能且合理的”解释，可以解释这些不寻常的伤害。
The mysterious items had pierced through Margaret's clothing. A forensic expert who analyzed the clothing said she couldn't rule out the possibility that a tail comb had caused the damage, but it also could have been any other thin, blunt instrument such as a screen. screwdriver or knitting needle. No evidence was presented that put Robert Penny at the scene of the crime or indicated he'd arranged for someone to carry out the murders on his behalf. Focus was therefore placed on a possible motive. Witnesses were called to ascertain the exact dates that Robert began a romantic relationship
这些神秘的物体刺穿了玛格丽特的衣服。一位分析衣服的法医专家表示，她不能排除尾梳造成损坏的可能性，但也可能是任何其他细长的钝器，如螺丝刀或织针。没有证据表明罗伯特·彭尼出现在犯罪现场，也没有证据表明他安排了某人代他实施谋杀。因此，重点放在了可能的动机上。证人被传唤以确定罗伯特开始与他的第二任妻子金建立浪漫关系的具体日期。
with his second wife, Kim. Kim claimed the relationship didn't become intimate until several months after Margaret's murder, which was verified by her daughter who was living with the couple at the time. No evidence was forthcoming to indicate the two had been romantically involved while Margaret was still alive. While various witnesses expressed their opinion that Robert Penny didn't grieve appropriately following his wife's death, evidence was also presented to the contrary. Some believed that Robert was clearly traumatised and had grieved intensely for a long period of time. Counsel appearing for Claire Aycock's family described the circumstantial evidence against Robert Penny as extraordinary.
金声称直到玛格丽特被谋杀几个月后，两人的关系才变得亲密，这一点得到了当时与这对夫妇住在一起的女儿的证实。没有证据表明两人在玛格丽特还活着时就有浪漫关系。虽然各种证人表达了他们认为罗伯特·彭尼在妻子死后没有表现出适当悲伤的观点，但也提出了相反的证据。一些人认为罗伯特显然受到了创伤，并长时间地深切悲痛。代表克莱尔·艾科克斯家属的律师将针对罗伯特·彭尼的间接证据描述为“非同寻常”。
Summing up, they said, Robert Penny was either involved in the murder of his wife and Claire Aycox, or he was the victim of the most remarkable confluence of misfortune and his own strange behaviour, that it strains credibility. The coroner agreed that some comments made by Robert were highly unusual, but that overall, a majority of the circumstantial evidence was open to different interpretations. The coroner concluded that Robert Penny was not involved in the murders of Claire Aycox or Margaret Penny in any capacity, stating, The prosecution of Mr Penny gave great hope to the Acox and Penny families about the prospect of closure or finality to a pain so immeasurably etched into their hearts.
总结时，他们说：“罗伯特·彭尼要么参与了谋杀他的妻子和克莱尔·艾科克斯，要么他是一系列最引人注目的不幸巧合和他自己奇怪行为的受害者，这令人难以置信。”验尸官同意罗伯特所做的一些评论非常不寻常，但总体而言，大部分间接证据可以有不同的解读。验尸官得出结论，罗伯特·彭尼没有以任何身份参与克莱尔·艾科克斯或玛格丽特·彭尼的谋杀案，并表示：“对彭尼先生的起诉给了艾科克斯和彭尼家族极大的希望，让他们看到了结束或终结这种深深铭刻在他们心中的痛苦的前景。”
The threads of circumstantial evidence, evidence when woven together have given the perception that Mr Penny was a plausible suspect. However, those threads begin to unravel, and as they are analyzed alone and as a whole, as has been done in this inquest, the likelihood of Mr. Penny's involvement fades, and many of the questions remain painfully unanswered. The coroner couldn't determine whether the man Robert Menzel had seen running from the scene had anything to do with the crime, and said that other persons of interest, including Gordon and Russell Smith, could not be excluded. Her report concluded,
“当间接证据的线索交织在一起时，给人一种彭尼先生是一个合理嫌疑人的印象。然而，这些线索开始解开，正如在这次研讯中所做的那样，当它们被单独和整体分析时，彭尼先生参与的可能性就消失了，许多问题仍然痛苦地悬而未决。”验尸官无法确定罗伯特·门泽尔看到从现场跑开的男子是否与犯罪有关，并表示包括戈登和拉塞尔·史密斯在内的其他相关人员不能被排除。她的报告总结道：
This was a heinous and violent crime committed against two innocent women whose lives were tragically cut short. I acknowledge these crimes have immeasurably impacted the lives of the friends and family of Mrs. Penny and Mrs. Acox and cast a dark shadow over the community of Portland. Based upon the available evidence, I am unable to identify the person or persons who murdered Mrs. Penny and Mrs. Acox. Therefore, the murders remain unsolved and this homicide investigation remains open. As of early 2024, the murders of Claire Acox and Margaret Penny are still unsolved. The building on the corner of Julia and Bentink Streets has since been repainted, the old-landed, London signage covered up. But paint can't cover old wounds. After 32 years, some residents of
“这是一起针对两名无辜女性的令人发指的暴力犯罪，她们的生命被悲剧性地缩短了。我承认这些罪行对彭尼夫人和艾科克斯夫人的朋友和家人的生活产生了不可估量的影响，并给波特兰社区蒙上了一层阴影。根据现有证据，我无法确定杀害彭尼夫人和艾科克斯夫人的凶手。因此，谋杀案仍然未破，这起凶杀案调查仍然开放。”截至2024年初，克莱尔·艾科克斯和玛格丽特·彭尼的谋杀案仍然未破。朱莉娅街和本廷克街拐角处的建筑此后被重新粉刷，旧的“伦敦”招牌被覆盖。但油漆无法掩盖旧伤。32年后，一些波特兰居民
Portland still go out of their way to avoid walking past the old London building, haunted by the memories of what happened inside. Theories remain about who was responsible for the grizzly crime. Other convicted killers have been considered and ruled out over time. The identity of the so-called horrible man remains a mystery, although it is possible he was an innocent individual who was too embarrassed or fearful to come forward to clear his name. The check stolen from the salon on the day of the slaying has never been cached. The bloody footprint found at the scene remains a key piece of evidence, although investigators can't say with certainty whether the print was left by the killer or someone who sullied the crime scene prior to it being cordoned off.
仍然会特意绕道，避免走过伦敦老建筑，被里面发生的事情的记忆所困扰。关于谁应对这起可怕的犯罪负责的理论依然存在。随着时间的推移，其他被定罪的杀手也被考虑过并被排除。所谓的“可怕男人”的身份仍然是一个谜，尽管他可能是一个无辜的人，因为太尴尬或害怕而不敢挺身而出以洗清自己的名义。案发当天从理发店偷走的支票从未被兑现。在现场发现的血脚印仍然是一个关键证据，尽管调查人员无法确定该脚印是凶手留下的，还是在现场被封锁之前弄脏犯罪现场的人留下的。
The existence of DNA and fingerprint evidence means there's a possibility this case could one day be solved and the reward for information still exists. Until that day comes, the families of Claire Aycock's and Margaret Penny will continue to seek answers. Claire's son, Tim, told the age newspaper that he wouldn't wish the experience on anyone, saying, It's consumed the latter half of our lives. It's daily. It's confronting. It wears you down. What it is about now is closure. Someone held to account. Speaking to author Leonie Wallace, Tim said, The last thing I can and need to do for mum is to witness justice being carried out. Until then, we will always be wondering, who, why? What if? The murders led to an irreparable fracture between the Penny family.
DNA和指纹证据的存在意味着这个案件有一天可能会被解决，悬赏信息仍然有效。在那一天到来之前，克莱尔·艾科克斯和玛格丽特·彭尼的家人将继续寻求答案。克莱尔的儿子蒂姆告诉《时代报》，他不希望任何人有这种经历，他说：“它消耗了我们后半生的生活。这是每天的。这是令人面对的。它让你精疲力竭。现在重要的是结束。有人要负责。”在与作者利奥妮·华莱士交谈时，蒂姆说：“我能为妈妈做的最后一件事，也是我需要做的，就是见证正义得到伸张。在那之前，我们将永远在想，谁，为什么？如果呢？”谋杀案导致了彭尼家族之间不可弥补的裂痕。
Not only had Jacqueline and Anthony lost their mother, their suspicion against Robert changed their relationship with their father. The relationship between the siblings also suffered in the wake of the crime, and Anthony eventually changed his name. Margaret's daughter Jacqueline told Leone Wallace, You never get over it. there's not one day where you don't play detective in your own head. It just never goes away.
杰奎琳和安东尼不仅失去了母亲，他们对罗伯特的怀疑也改变了他们与父亲的关系。兄弟姐妹之间的关系也在犯罪发生后受到了影响，安东尼最终改了名字。玛格丽特的女儿杰奎琳告诉利奥妮·华莱士：“你永远无法克服它。没有一天你不在自己的脑海里扮演侦探。它就是永远不会消失。”
Claire's husband Peter spent years wondering what his wife's last words were. A few years after the murders, he told the warnable standard that he'd love to have a few minutes of the killer's time. Peter said, I'd like to speak with him, even if he just called me up and told me he did it. I would like to know how he feels knowing about the pain he's inflicted on others and the hurt that others have got to endure because of his actions. While Peter was thankful for all the support he received from the Portland community following Claire's death, he felt like no one could understand his pain and suffering unless they'd been through something similar.
克莱尔的丈夫彼得花了几年时间想知道他妻子的遗言是什么。谋杀案发生几年后，他告诉《沃南布尔标准报》，他很想有几分钟时间和凶手谈谈。彼得说：“我想和他谈谈，即使他只是打电话给我，告诉我他做了这件事。我想知道他知道自己给别人造成的痛苦，以及别人因为他的行为而不得不忍受的伤害时，他是什么感觉。”虽然彼得感谢克莱尔死后波特兰社区给予他的所有支持，但他觉得除非经历过类似的事情，否则没有人能理解他的痛苦和折磨。
Peter said, I know of people who used to complain about people snoring, but snoring can be the best music in the world. Ask any widow. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
彼得说：“我知道有人曾经抱怨别人打呼噜，但打呼噜可能是世界上最好的音乐。问问任何寡妇就知道了。”本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。